ladies and gentlemen welcome back have
we got a show for you today
today on coffeezilla and webinar
wednesday i am learning
gongfu from the secret death touch
master
and i'm going and trying it out on a
friend of mine
who will prevail we're going to find out
today if you guys don't know hey
first of all welcome back to the channel
i'm your host coffee zilla the internet
detective in the 10 million dollar
studio
but before we get into this this is
webinar wednesday which means we get
scammed so you don't have to we buy
these shady products you see all around
you and put them to the test
we find out are they fact or fiction
okay i mean you best believe it's gonna
get weird
it's gonna get wild and uh yeah without
further ado let's just jump into this
okay
today we're looking at
[Music]
secretdeathtouches.com
or dot net or something like that
i killed bruce lee oh you're about to
hear that shocking deathbed confession
from a martial arts master assassin
you'll see how he made the kung fu
legends brain explode inside his head
by using a near mythical chinese death
touch
a death touch and who's this guy you'll
learn the same forbidden technique
yourself
along with 10 more highly lethal
one-touch
death moves okay i told you
did i not tell you that it's gonna be a
great show we're gonna learn in this
video
one touch death moves we're gonna get
scammed by whatever this guy's selling
we will buy it
we will learn the one touch death moves
and i will be trying them out on a
friend of mine
now beware these techniques will disable
[ __ ] and even kill any attacker
threatening the safety
of you or your loved ones plus it's
guaranteed to work no matter how old you
are
what your physical condition is or even
if the assailant is heavily oh
oh you're going after seniors with the
scam got it got it got it one touch
death moves guys you poke them and they
just fall they fall to the ground
and completely disable i mean what is it
gonna be you know kick them in the balls
what what other death move is there
everyone needs these
death moves in their arsenal why why no
no they don't dude if you're teaching a
class at a school you don't need a
uh i take that back maybe in the u.s
maybe you do
need one-touch death moves and i do mean
everyone
even an old marine like of course i
spent 20 years in the circle no you did
it
no you did it this is a script this
guy's reading a script
he got hired for five bucks off fiverr i
bet
but even i was completely unprepared
when two men pulled a gun
on my grandchildren i mean we were in
the parking lot of a toy store can you
believe that they actually acted this
out
for a fake story they had like guys
pretend to mug
children the bigger guy put a nine
millimeter to my head
he told me luckily the camera crew was
there to capture it wouldn't think
twice about splattering brains all over
the concrete i didn't do
what he said i gave them everything they
asked for my wallet
cell phone car keys those even took the
shopping bag filled with a new lego set
i just bought for my group
yeah this is just to stir up the
emotions guys you gotta make your
viewers scared
bring them into your emotional situation
say hey without death moves
even if you're a 20-year retired marine
you're in trouble
listen i'm going to be honest this whole
story is starting to sound a little
implausible
a bunch of lego hunting robbers are in
the middle of the day going up to you
and holding a gun to your head
in the middle of the day in broad
daylight and your kids are screaming
their head off
that's their strategy interesting i
tried comforting my poor grandkids who
of course were
scared out of their wits and little
daniel even had an accident during the
mugging which
[Music]
i'm just thinking about how they film
this what kind of psycho has built this
little
funnel this is ridiculous my mission
brought me to the deathbed of a martial
arts master
who had honed his craft for more than 70
years
a man who in his last dying breaths made
a confession to me that will shock the
world
i killed bruce lee at first i didn't
believe him
i mean seriously but after learning his
forbidden
one touch death it was impossible
what are we watching listen i swear i
have the best job
i really do guys this is what i do it
for it's not for
dunking on dan lok it's not for ty lopez
it's for one touch
death moves who else like this is like
watching mortal kombat
but people are trying to pass this off
as if it's real i think that's
that's what's great about it is like
this guy really wants you not only to
believe but
buy from him one touch death moves
from a master assassin who killed bruce
lee
anyone can master these in a matter of
days even if you could barely walk
without a cane
you're 90 years old and you weigh a
hundred pounds dripping wet
inside the short part okay now this is
the stuff
this is marketers go too far they're
like hey you're in your geriatric ward
you can learn this one touch death move
grand gran
ain't killing nobody let's be real the
only way she's doing it was is with a
glock 9.
it's not with your martial arts one
touch death move now let's cut right to
it
my name is robert lawrence okay i got to
give this guy credit for it so far i've
been roasting him
he can really deliver the serious thing
he's really got like this serious face
i'm like
let's get right to it and when i offered
to take them out for ice cream or to go
back to the toy store
they threw fits because they were too
afraid
they just didn't feel safe with grandpa
anymore okay
come on dude come on
oh grandpa didn't get to see his
grandbabies anymore because he hadn't
learned the one-touch death moves yet
basically he finds out about these one
touch death moves and goes on a search
for who can teach them to him but then i
got a bizarre email that would
ultimately change everything that's how
it always is it's always a bizarre email
the subject line simply said the way and
the email was from china
inside it was a little bit racist but
okay
you know it's credible because it's from
china you know those chinese guys short
paragraph but what it said
made my heart race you want to know the
way of the death touch
i have been waiting for this question my
whole life but you will need to come to
china okay so he goes to china
uh he learns of this old man who's on
his deathbed
okay even though they were so effortless
lee claimed each one would allow me to
disable any attacker in a matter of
seconds this
he said was extremely important because
if i wanted to simply knock a person to
his knees
all it would take was a flick okay
let's get to the point here guys people
you guys don't care about this you don't
care about
lee you want to know i mean
do they work so i bought it ladies and
gentlemen when you buy this thing you
get two things you get a pdf
a little inspirational booklet that i
guess shares the moves with you and then
you get a video
that uh is visual demonstration of the
moves now the book
is amazing and hilarious i'm going to
share a very small portion preview
with you for a second here really it's
like a fictional story of somebody
using these okay so basically our little
hero
uh in our story he he had been training
on this dummy and one of his friends
comes up to him
and he goes oh yeah you can't you've
just been poking at a stuffed dummy you
don't know martial art
that's fine i said dismissively you can
believe whatever you want
no said greg getting angry you need to
prove
these techniques of yours actually work
i hesitated maybe he was right maybe i
needed to test them out
okay big guy you come at me with your
best move apparently greg was like an
actual
like fighter you know buff whatever you
come at me with your best move and we'll
see who comes out on top
you got it twerp but i'm warning you now
he said i'm gonna knock your block off
greg stood back and stretched his thick
muscles as he prepared to attack me
i visualized the pressure points on his
body just as i had done with the stuffed
dummy back in china
i assumed hit my stance and so did greg
you ready little man
i nodded greg came at me with the long
steps with his arms waving in the air i
breathed and relaxed as master lee has
told me to
and then we go to full sci-fi time
seemed to slow down
i could see how inefficient greg's
movements were all the energy
poured into them accomplished nothing i
could see the exact spot on his body
that i would attack
he swung his body in a lumbering
roundhouse kick but before it connected
i reached out with a single tiger strike
to his abdomen and barely touched him
at first i thought i missed the target i
ducked yet greg gave a jolt and howled
in gurgling cry of pain
spontaneously he vomited all over my
garage floor
and collapsed into it there and lay
there unmoving
call an ambulance i replied i think i
may have killed him
okay that's what we're dealing with
that's part one
okay part two let's learn what the
secret look we've heard all about the
death touch moves
but what are the death touch moves guys
hi i'm brad potts today we're going to
be working on some self-defense moves
now i myself
what's this about self-defense moves
where's the death touch moves okay so
the first technique we're going to be
addressing today is the
one touch disabling technique it's
called a death move
gary what's your name oh brad brad it's
definitely not called a disabling move
it's called a death move
please get that right well the first
thing we're going to do is make a fist
with
a projected index finger like something
you're going to break your finger
like so then we're going to use this
punch into the
sensitive areas of your would-be
attacker for example the eyes
the sternum the solar plexus
what what is this just your opponent is
effectively disabling them by obscuring
yeah if you get a wind up like that brad
if your guy's gonna just stand there you
can just poke him in the eye sure
the second technique is the jaw attack
where the hand is
thrust
[Laughter]
dude dude you mean just choking somebody
you can't be grand grand in doing that
dude you have to like beat
arnold schwarzenegger for that to work
like really lift them up
this is a punch to the solar plexus
this painful technique is extremely
effective in that it can cause
gastrointestinal distress as
you're you're going from a one-touch
death move
to gastrointestinal distress
the bait switch of a lifetime ladies and
gentlemen can we get to a death touch
move please
oh here we go this looks good seeing is
the good old heel to the pelvis
you've been kicking the balls it's an
ancient
chinese secret guys from the far east
master lee told it to us no one ever
heard of it before
now if you're being frontally attacked
particularly ladies look at this poor
man
look at his face he's just praying that
foot doesn't go any farther
you can see him flinch a little bit it's
a good thing to strike oh
he's like really trying not to move
there eel and this is done in a snapping
up motion sending the testicles
far into the intestinal tract
sending the testicles far oh far into
the intestinal tract okay what else do
we have let's go
and striking vigorously into the atoms
oh god
let's just get through this thing huh
what is this
extremely effective and then it can none
of these moves are extremely effective
let me promise you that no one's going
to be sitting there
what what is this what have you done to
this man brad potts once and for
all this could cause renal shut down
renal bleeding
brad how did you get behind your
would-be attacker
active technique if for whatever reason
your opponent
exposes his back to you even brad
doesn't believe this is likely
look at his face right now look he's
gonna try to say this with a straight
face and he's like what am i teaching
right now
i guess if the lego toy sets on the line
this is justified
the next technique we're going to be
discussing is if your attacker comes at
you with a knife
the first thing you want to do is block
the knife
block it with a heart oh god the worst
thing you can do is tell people to
fight somebody with a knife you're going
to get killed hard part of your foot
this is actually dangerous advice this
is danger do not fight people with a
knife
anyone who does actual real martial arts
please actually uh
please please comment in the description
i mean like seriously this is ridiculous
okay so we didn't find our death move
anywhere with brad brad was completely
useless to us
never do anything this man said but i
did find our death touch move
somewhere deep within our fictional
story here apparently
it's called the snake bite by far the
most deadly move in all of denmark
and by far the most secret it's so
simple and deadly it's only taught
to dim mac masters but luckily we're
going to learn it today ladies and
gentlemen the reason it's called the
snake bite ladies and gentlemen is
because you make a shadow puppet
and you strike them in the temple and
this brings me to a little uh secret
about me guys
you don't know about little personal
anecdote for you you see ladies and
gentlemen when i was
a young buck i actually took gunfu
i know it might seem like i'm joking but
this
is my green belt from those days can you
see that
not really coming through on the screen
for some reason like
what the why's the green belt not coming
through i don't i don't know
anyways yeah this is real when i was 14
i learned
the art of gongfu the people who taught
me actually
learned it for real but my point is is
that i
oh there it goes i should be qualified
to use this move i mean don't think that
this is gonna be user error because
technically
i've trained in the art of gung fu so i
should be ready to
snake bite someone so i decided what
better
person to challenge this on not just a
random person down the street
i got my friend james who's an actual
jujitsu
uh roller i don't know what you guys
call yourselves jiu-jitsu practitioner
for years
and i'm gonna absolutely destroy him
with the
new death touches that i learned so come
with me we're going outside of the
studio for the first time
ever i think and we're gonna go take our
our lessons
on the street i hope you enjoy what
happens next
i think it's gonna work i think i'm
gonna hurt him i'm happy about it
because he's had this coming for a long
time i'm gonna be honest with you
oh it's not gonna work he's gonna hurt
[Music]
himself
all right not so sure about these uh
death moves guys
but i'm back in my studio it's night
time now uh it's late obviously been a
long day
but i hope you enjoyed this video hope
you had a laugh uh don't do these
ridiculous
you know death touch things look martial
arts are great
but they're great if you actually apply
them so yeah i hope you enjoy this this
is
an entertaining one for me and let me
know who you want to see
me take next take seriously whose course
do we take
next i mean we've been through the
ringer so far tai lopez death touches
tell me what's next on the document in
the comment below thank you for watching
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you